do you think virginity is a scam yeah
it's a patriarchal scam it was just
created so we would all
feel bad about having sexual experiences
or
or to control women and so i always tell
people that you can have your virginity
back it only costs 40 dollars to me
um and then i will send you your v card
this goes for you too conan i know you
have a child but that does not matter
i have two i have i have two children uh
but you know they're they're still on
the young side i
and i lost my virginity very recently it
was
uh during obama's sec it was during
obama's second term
and i remember it very well yeah second
term obama yeah i'm so i waited i
i waited i was very good boy um
or mentally ill i don't know what the
problem was but i know um
yeah i so so what you're saying is
you're going to sell people
for 40 you'll sell them a card that
restores them their virginity
if that's what they want absolutely
everyone can be a virgin again and i
want to make that happen
that's my gift to society if they come
across with the money
yes okay so your gift to society is
something that you're going to try and
make a lot of money out of
okay well is there such a thing as a
free gift you know we always get
something out of
anything that we do whether it be purely
altruistic
you know so i get it i get it i get what
you're saying you're what you're saying
is that everything
is at the end of the day some kind of a
scam even if you're giving money to a
charity
you get to feel good about yourself
because you gave money to the charity
so in a way you're getting something out
of it
exactly so yeah you get to feel good so
there's really just truly not like
an altruistic moment that doesn't give
you something positive in return
whether it's a good feeling or
encouragement
uh you know you still get something so i
get 40 and you get your virginity
okay all right well i would like that
card please i want my virginity back
because i'll send that right over conan
yeah thank you it was the
it was the best uh 42 years of my life
yes come on back i'll be in my office
on third street